Patrick where does the movie start for
you it's a good question where does the
movie start I think a movie starts with
just a sort of a genuine intrigue or
interest in something or passion and
something our film wordplay it's about
the New York Times crossword puzzle we
love that puzzle we do it all the time I
grew up in kind of a puzzle family where
we jigsaw puzzles and played Scrabble
and boggle and things like that so that
just felt very it felt like home to me
it really did and Will Shortz who's the
star of our film is sort of the star of
the crossword puzzle world if you will
so that felt like a very good fit with I
OH USA our second film that was you know
my brother and my brother-in-law and a
lot of my very good friends from Chicago
are they work in the bond trading
business they worked the chicago board
of trade so I've been hearing about Alan
Greenspan and I've been hearing about
you know the the Federal Reserve and the
national debt and interest rates and
inflation and I've been hearing about
all those things for a very very long
time from from my friends and family but
I you know I didn't I didn't really have
a clear understanding of any of that
frankly so when the idea of making this
film came up it felt like a way to kind
of catch up with my friends and my
family and and to be able to certainly
rely on them for a lot of advice and
help as we made the film and also to
sort of make a movie about their world
which we did and really really enjoyed
it so again that felt like a good fit
and with with if you build it
really I mean the reason that filmed got
made is that a very good friend of ours
brought that idea to us our friend Neal
Baer who was a writer and and showrunner
at the show ER and then he went on to
become the head writer and showrunner at
law and order SVU he's currently the
showrunner of a show called under the
dome which is on CBS Neil is just
incredibly successful he's a wonderful
person and and and a very very
intelligent very kind person he Emily
pillet in the star of if you build it
had written a book that he loved and he
brought this idea to us and Christina
and I loved it too in fact almost
instantly this idea of you know creative
problem solving and design and
architecture take all that and put it
into a high school see what happens like
to us almost immediately we're like okay
so this is kind of like like this old
house that TV show which I loved and the
breakfast club it's like a mash-up of
those two ideas so we're like well that
that's cool that that could be really
fun and in a way that's kind of what our
movies about in a way so I think I think
you know I think that if you can if you
can sort of see the movie before you
make it and what you see really makes
sense then you're probably about to
about to head down the right path
you